now Prague played B5 just attacking The
Rook The Rook Retreat it and now
wow Knight takes D5 here double
exclamation mark from Prague what a move
we've shown how strong this move can be
with the queen coming in let's get up to
date with the position the only chance
really black has here is to try and get
the Queens off so he does but the
problem with this
is that now
you put the black rook in a very bad
Square so Knight B6 picks up the Rook
the king moves Knight takes C8
and it even here requires very careful
calculation because it looks like black
is going to get some material back
but Rook A6 played allowing black to get
material back and he simply takes on E6
he's so cool to play these moves right
because even here I wouldn't be 100
confident I'm winning I'd be like it's
equal material it is but Prague has
worked out
that this Pawn is going to be too strong
and his Rook is going to start doing the
Hoover and start picking up on so what's
a great idea on screen uh Simon that
prag has done it he has beaten purgesh
and he is through to the quarterfinals